you write about life and death
uh sort of at the biological level is
the does the question of suicide why
live
does the question of why the human mind
is capable of depression are you able to
um introspect that from a place of
biology
why
our minds why we humans can go to such
dark places
why can we commit suicide
why
can we
go
you know suffer
suffer period but also suffer from
a feeling of meaninglessness of um going
to a dark place that depression can take
you is this a feature of life or is it a
bug
um
i don't know i mean if it's a feature of
life then i suppose it would have to be
true of other organisms as well and i
don't know
you're talking about dogs earlier on and
they can certainly be
very
sad and upset and may mooch for days
after their owner died or something like
that so i suspect in some sense it's a
feature of biology um
it's probably a feature of mortality
it's a probably
but beyond all of that
i mean i guess there's two ways you
could come at it there's one of them
would be to say well
you can
effectively do the math and come to the
conclusion that it's all pointless
and there's really no point in me being
here any longer
um
and maybe that's true in the greater
scheme of things
you can justify yourself in terms of
society but society will be gone soon
enough as well and you end up with a
very bleak place just by logic
in some sense it's surprising that we
can find any meaning at all
well maybe this is where consciousness
comes in that we we have transient joy
but with transient joy we have transient
misery as well and and sometimes with
everything in biology
um getting the regulation right is
practically impossible you will always
have a bell-shaped curve where some
people unfortunately are at the joy end
and some people are at the misery end
and um you know that's the way brains
are wired and
i doubt there's ever an escape from that
it's the same with sex and everything
else as well we're dealing with it
whether you know you you can't regulate
it so
it's um
any anything goes it's all part of
biology
you